So we're going to continue talking
about a tissue engineering. Uh,
today I introduced the subject on a
Tuesday and I'm going to talk about some
more examples that sort
of illustrate this,
a new approach to creating
a medical therapies.
And so I just wanted to
remind you before about the,
about the two readings that are already
posted on the website and to encourage
you to uh, to look at those, um,
to get a sense for how the field has
developed over the last 20 years or so.
So,
and,
and last time I use this sort
of outline as a guide to have,
uh, at least my view of the
characteristics of tissue engineering.
We talked about it at the beginning of
class last time as a logical extension of
conventional medical and
surgical practices. And, uh,
in that sense a solution,
potentially a solution to the,
to the limited,
a number of donor donor organs that
are available to treat diseases where
transplantation of tissue is the only,
only option that many approaches to tissue
engineering involve regulating your,
your body's natural response.
We can heal in many cases and regenerate.
And the liver is a,
for example,
is a fabulously regenerative Oregon.
If you go into a laboratory animal like a,
like a rat,
if you remove two thirds of their liver,
their liver will regard grow within
a period of a couple of weeks.
The liver has an amazing
regenerative capacity,
but there are human diseases where that
regenerative capacity is overwhelmed. Um,
and uh,
infection can be that kind of a disease.
Hepatitis infection for example.
Cirrhosis is that kind of infection.
And when you,
when you get past the body's
natural ability to heal itself,
then transplantation is the only option.
And in tissue engineering we might be
thinking about a different strategy.
Could we provide some,
um,
some support for the
body's own ability to heal?
Could you provide a little bit of extra
liver tissue that would allow the body
and opportunity to compensate
for, uh, for its loss?
So, so tissue engineering involves control
or regulation of the normal healing
process. And a, today I'm going
to start by talking about, uh,
how it attempts to replace or supplement
the sailor component of disease tissues.
When, uh, when a tissue
is diseased, for example,
when we talked about the,
um,
the coronary arteries
and needing a bypass,
you're adding extra cells or extra
tissue there because medical therapies,
at least the ones we have now are not
effective at reestablishing the blood flow
pathway,
right?
So you're adding new cells and they
have to be cells that are in the correct
configuration,
right?
They have to be sells like a vessel and
they have to be performing the function
that cells ordinarily provide.
And I talked about how we couldn't use
completely synthetic materials to replace
that blood vessel,
even though a synthetic material would
provide a conduit for blood because the
material properties aren't right,
it isn't the same as the
natural cellular layer,
then blood coagulates on the surface,
it doesn't provide that normal
function that sales provide.
So we want to think about ways to replace
or supplement that cellular component.
Okay.
So let me talk about one example.
And this is an example
that, um, that, that uh,
I've been working on in my
own lab together with uh,
two different laboratories at the medical
school, Jordan Poba in immunology. And,
um,
and Al Bothwell in immunology.
And it really uses a strategy that's been
used in laboratories around the world
to try to reestablish
a tissues in animals.
And the technique is fairly straight
forward in shown in this cartoon that,
uh,
cells are cultured.
So these are a special cells in a,
in a couple of different ways.
One is they are human cells and they are
harvested from human umbilical veins,
right?
So the umbilical vein,
which is normally discarded
after delivery, the baby is born,
the umbilical cord and the
placenta are ordinarily discarded.
If you keep that tissue,
you can isolate the cells that
form the lining of that tissue.
It's a vein.
And what you get from this isolation are
endothelial cells and it's abbreviated
here. H, U. V, e. C Hugh Vec.
That stands for human umbilical
vein endothelial cells.
And people have learned over the past,
uh,
past few decades how to maintain these
cells in culture, how to propagate them,
how to increase them, a number using the
same techniques we talked about. Uh, neat,
very near the beginning of the course.
They've also discovered how to genetically
modify these cells so that they
perform better in culture.
And one of these modifications is to add
a gene called BCL two and BCL two is a
survival gene that allows these cells to
live beyond when you would expect them
to live.
If you just take human umbilical vein
and Athelia cells and you propagate them
in culture, you can, you
can, you can passage them.
You remember the process of passaging
from one tissue culture to another,
always getting more and more cells.
You can do that for some
limited period of time,
but if you give them this
survival gene BCL two,
you can do that for a much longer period
of time. You can get more cells, right?
So cells are grown from
human, uh, from human tissues.
Now the idea is to somehow get these
cells into an animal or into a patient and
get them to reform blood
vessels inside the patient.
And the way that,
uh,
this has done is that these cells are
suspended in a three dimensional jail.
So this is a gel of Collagen and it
looks just like this scanning electron
micrograph on the side.
If you look at very high magnification,
it's just a web or a network of protein
fibers formed from the natural protein
Collagen.
And we talked about Collin's role in
the extra cellular matrix earlier here.
This is,
this is isolated Collagen,
purified and then formed into a gel
and cells are suspended within it.
That's what this picture down here is to
show you. This is a high magnification.
A cell in here would be almost the same
size as this whole picture would be a
cell.
And so you can imagine each cell,
but suspended in this three dimensional
material is surrounded by a webbing of
protein fibers, right? And
it has a thickness, right?
So unlike normal cell culture where
we grow in flat on a plastic dish,
these cells are suspended
within a three dimensional jail.
Now there's something else in this
gel here, and that's shown here.
These are particles, particles
made of the, uh, of the, uh,
material algenate and in
section a few weeks ago,
you all made particles like this, right?
We made them with food coloring in them.
Uh, but you, you, you learn the
process. It's quite straight forward.
And imagine that instead of putting
a food coloring in it like we did,
you put in a protein and you selected
that protein to be one that encourages
blood vessels to form.
It's a protein that your body naturally
uses to cause blood vessels to form more
readily.
And that protein is called vascular
endothelial growth factor or vegf.
It's not important the details,
but it's a,
it's a signal that the body
uses to form new blood vessels.
We've isolated it,
purified it,
and encapsulated in these tiny particles
which are then suspended with the cells
in the jail.
So what you have here is something that
you might call a neo tissue. Uh, what,
what we would like to become a tissue
when we implant it back into the animal.
It's not a tissue yet.
It's a collection of cells
and extracellular matrix
and signaling molecules that
are arranged in a three
dimensional structure.
And the hope is that if you put these
back into a patient or put them back into
an animal,
like the mouse shown here,
that you would grow new blood vessels.
Okay.
That's the hope.
So how does this work?
And this is some early
work that was done by, uh,
Jordan [inaudible] here
in the school of medicine.
And there's a lot of pictures here.
This is from a paper that I could give
you if you're interested in reading in
more detail,
but I want you to focus on this one here.
So what they did was they,
instead of taking this gel and
putting it right into the animal,
they maintained it and culture for awhile.
And the idea was that in culture you
can control the conditions that the neo
tissue develops within.
And maybe you can control them in such a
way that the tissue gets a start toward
being what you would like it to be.
And in this green picture here,
I don't know if you can see it,
but this posted online and you could
blow it up and take a look at it. Um,
what you see is that these cells have
organized into tube like structures and
you'll see tubes clearly here in
this jail where you don't see them.
So clearly in the other green images here.
So these are the cells
I talked about before,
the ones that are genetically modified
with the survival protein so that they
survive in culture.
And it turns out that
this survival protein also
encourages their formation into
tube,
like structures that are starting to
look like blood vessels if you wait the
proper period of time and then
implant these gels into a mouse.
So here they just made a small incision
in the skin and slip the gel underneath
the skin and left it there.
Then these tubes develop
into blood vessels.
Now that would be cool enough on its own,
but it does something more in that this
gel that's now filled with blood vessels
does two things. One is that the
vessels start to differentiate.
Some become like capillaries,
some become like veins,
some become like arteries and they start
to connect to the vascular system of
the mouse.
And so if you wait long enough and you
look by electron microscopy inside these
gels, you will find many, many
blood vessels that look like this.
This is a cross section in this panel.
Be Below.
You can see the endothelial cells have
formed into a capillary. It's a tube.
Not only is it a tube, but here's a
mouse blood cell inside of it. It's a,
it's a tube that's now carrying
mouse blood through it.
So you've created new pathways
for blood to flow right now.
That's a neat trick.
And you could imagine using
that to treat disease.
One way you might use it to treat disease
is to implant these things into areas
of the body that where there
aren't enough blood vessels.
For example, um, many, uh, many, uh, um,
uh, adults, uh,
get vascular deficiencies in their legs
and these could result from trauma,
some from just the
natural process of aging.
Some from diseases like diabetes and the
blood vessels in your legs don't work
anymore. And if you're not
delivering enough blood to your leg,
the tissues become ischemic
or derive deprived of oxygen.
But what if you put one of these
patches into that area where you weren't
getting enough blood flow and you could
create new blood flow and that's what
this experiment shows here.
Treating an ischemic limb with one
of these patches and what you see
particularly in high magnification is
that lots and lots of new blood vessels
form and they connect back to the major
vessels that are already in the leg,
so you've created new blood flow pathways.
One could imagine using this in
the heart for example as well.
When you have tissue that's deprived
of oxygen because of a heart attack,
for example, or loss of
flow. That's one idea.
Another idea is that you could use these
to create sort of miniature organs in
that what if instead of just
putting endothelial cells in there,
we put other cells in there as well.
What if you put liver cells in together
with the endothelial cells and the
signaling molecules? What if you put
cells from the pancreas in there?
Then maybe this gel would develop
not only into a vascularized tissue,
but into a vascularized tissue that
contained liver cells or cells from the
pancreas or sales from the kidney.
And maybe those cells would start
to function like a little tissue,
right? So maybe you could
make a system that supports
deliver. In the case of the natural
liver is developing. This is,
this is one of the central
ideas of tissue engineering.
Okay. One of the other, uh, um,
that I think illustrates one
of the reasons why tissue
engineering has become a
viable alternative at this
point in our scientific, uh,
in the scientific culture.
Because we know how to culture cells,
we know how to genetically manipulate
cells and we know how to put them in these
kinds of micro environments
like I've shown.
The other thing that we've
learned how to do is look,
and I mentioned this last time,
is to make synthetic materials that
could serve as artificial extracellular
matrices.
And this slide shows a number of materials
that were made in laboratories here
at Yale. Uh, one of them
is a network of fibers.
Now this should look reminiscent to
the Collagen picture I showed you a few
slides ago,
right?
It looks like a a network of
fibers that are all wound together.
Now the fibers here are much bigger
than Collagen fibers. In fact,
a cell here would look very tiny on this
scanning electron micrograph where it
filled up the whole thing before.
So we're thinking about fibers
at a different scale, right?
These are large fibers.
In fact,
these are the same kinds of fibers that
are used same size and in some cases the
same actual fibers that are used to
make, uh, the materials in your clothing.
Clothing is made of fibers
that are woven together.
Now this is a non woven mesh,
so the fibers are randomly arranged,
but their fiber's not unlike the kinds
of fibers you would find in cloth
material that we make into
clothing at high magnification.
These are cylindrical fibers.
There's lots of space in between them.
And so you could fill these fibers up
with cells and cells would cling to the
fibers and potentially
grow within this scaffold.
This is a different kind of architecture
of a scaffold but made of the same sort
of material, synthetic polymers, uh,
but here instead of making fibers,
a porous structure was made
that looks like a sponge.
And so there are the walls of the
material that give it substance.
And there are lots of spaces in between,
much larger than sales that you
could fill up with sales. So why use,
why you synthetic materials when I all
you showed you an example of how you
could use a natural material. Well,
there's a couple of advantages.
One is that we know a lot about
how to process synthetic materials.
Now we can make them into almost anything
that you want and you can control
their structure on the microscopic
scale as I've shown here.
And you can control their structure
on the, on the larger scale as well,
which I'll show you in a few minutes.
Uh,
the other advantage is
that these particular, um,
these are different than the kinds of
fibers that are woven into clothing
because these intentionally
degrade over time.
So these are synthetic polymers that
will slowly dissolve over a period of
months.
And so one could make a scaffold,
build a tissue around it,
implanted in the body,
and then this scaffolding
which slowly disappear.
And what you hope is that as the,
during the time period when this
scaffolding scaffolding is disappearing,
genuine tissue is being
formed in its place. Okay.
And that's an advantage of
these materials as well.
That because they're polymers we can uh,
we can um,
control to a fairly high degree how
fast they degrade and what products they
degrade into.
So this shows you an example of tissue
engineering where these kinds of
materials I showed you on the last side.
So microscopically they'd look
like this up on the top panel here.
Macroscopically or with your eye.
This is just a photograph from a camera.
You could make these thick materials full
of all this webbing of fibers and you
could, you could form them into
different shapes, a triangle, a square,
or a cross in this shape here. Now because
this is a synthetic solid material,
it maintains its shape even
if you put it into water.
And because it's a porous material,
as I showed you before,
you could fill this up with cells.
And the experiment that was done
here is that these materials,
these porous materials were seated with
cells from cartilage and the cells that
make up cartilage are called chondracytes.
And so samples of Cartlidge were obtained,
digested down to individual cells.
Those cells were grown in culture until
you had a lot of them. And then sells.
We're put here, put here, put here,
and then they were
implanted back into animals.
And here's what comes out of the animal
several months later. And what you see,
uh, is material that looks
very much like Cartlidge.
Okay.
A couple of things are interesting.
One is that these things have maintained
their shapes even though they were
implanted into animals for many months.
So the shape that you make,
the original material in leads to
a tissue that's that same shape.
If you look microscopically
inside these tissues,
you'd find that they look like
Cartlidge in many respects.
They look like natural cartilage and that
is the chondracytes or the individual
cells that we put on here multiplied
inside the body, inside the scaffold,
and they filled it up.
They filled up the space.
And so the tissue that you get looks
like the scaffold that you use,
right?
This is a microscopic
image of some of those.
So imagine you cut this
one in it down the middle,
and then you looked under a microscope.
This is what normal cartilage looks like.
You can see the chondracytes
here, the white, uh, regions,
and the chondracytes excrete
an extra cellular matrix,
which is stained red in
this particular preparation.
If you look at this cartilage that
was formed by tissue engineering,
you'll see some structures here, some long
structures. These are residual fibers.
The polymer fibers haven't
completely degraded at this point,
but you see a lot of cells,
a lot of healthy cells,
and you see they're almost at the same
density that they are in the natural
cartilage.
So the cells have multiplied to reach
sort of a natural state and they're
secreting an extra cellular matrix.
They're making their own micro
environment by secreting molecules.
And so they also stain red.
Yeah.
Now it's not as deep.
Red is here.
They're not making as much
as natural cartilage do, but
they're on their way. And,
and um,
so here's an example of taking a material,
being able to fashion it into a
particular shape that you want.
Being able to control the microstructure
so that you can put cells in it in such
a way that the cells develop
into something that's
starting to look very much
like tissue. Now. Um,
okay,
this was done, um, in the late 1980s,
I believe. And at this time the
scientists that were doing it,
we're trying to make the point that there
was a lot of potential for this kind
of, of a, of a strategy.
And one place where white want
to make new cartilage is in, uh,
it plastic surgery. So people that, um,
that have lost tissue due to
cancer or to a birth defect,
maybe they're missing some
cartilage in their nose.
There are diseases where children are
born without functional cartridges,
cartilage in their rib cage.
There are even some traumas where
people might lose an ear, right?
In your ear is basically
skin covered with cartilage.
So they did this experiment mainly to make
a point and a, so I'll show it to you.
Instead of making a triangle
or a square or across,
they made a polymer scaffold that
looks a little bit like a human year.
Okay?
And they filled this scaffold.
This is 100% polymer.
Now there's no tissue in here.
But then they added a cartilage cells.
They added Chondracytes and they
implanted it back into an animal at a site
where they could easily see it. They
implanted it into the ear of a rabbit.
And over time,
what happened was the cartilage cells
that were in this scaffold grew into
cartilage in the same shape
as the scaffold that they use.
So here's a what looks like a human
ear growing on the ear of a rabbit.
All right?
Um,
so a dramatic demonstration if and when
they took this ear out of the rabbit,
obviously it, it's not a real ear.
It doesn't here, right? But it has,
it's all the cartilage that forms
the outer part of your year.
And if you took a section of
this later and looked inside,
it looked just like the
cartilage that's inside your ear.
Yeah.
Well you could use this same strategy
to make other kinds of tissues as well.
And I'm going to return to the example
of coronary arteries because that's such
a big medical problem around the world.
Coronary heart disease,
heart disease is either the number one
or number two killer around the world.
Certainly in countries that
are developed like the u s uh,
heart disease and cancer are
the leading causes of death.
And a lot of the deaths from heart disease
comes from failure of your coronary
arteries.
So one of the most performed surgical
operations in the United States is
coronary artery bypass surgery.
And you probably all know somebody who,
who has got it, maybe, maybe, uh,
maybe a grandparent or, um, or, or,
or a family friend.
And so it's not an uncommon surgery
and it's not perfect yet.
And we talked about the ways
that it's not perfect last time.
So what if you could grow outside of the
body blood vessels that you could use
to replace, uh, the vessels
inside of a patient.
And people have been working
on this for a long time.
So here's an initial attempt and this
is a tube that was made of a polymer and
in this case it was a polymer
was a natural polymer collagen.
So sort of like that college and Gel
that I talked about several slides ago,
that we suspended the endothelial
cells in only this time. It's um,
it's into the form of a tube.
And the idea was to take those endothelial
cells and coat the inside of this
tube with endothelial cells.
So make a tube that's mechanically strong,
that will stay like a tube,
but coated with the natural cells that
form the lining inside your blood vessels
and allow it to develop and culture
to the point where you have a natural
endothelial cell lining and then implant
this back into an animal in place of
its own artery.
And what you hope is that blood will flow
through here and it should flow cause
it's,
there's an opening and that the blood
won't clot because now instead of a
artificial material, you have a lining
of blood vessel cells on the inside,
right?
This is a picture, uh, from, uh,
studies that were done in the
early 1980s on this approach.
And there was some success. You could
make them work for some period of time,
but they always eventually failed.
And I won't go through
the whole history of this,
but there's a long history of
people trying different materials,
different ways of putting cells
on different sources of cells,
all the things that you could imagine
changing and all of them working for a
little while and then failing.
And you can imagine it's
a hard engineering problem
at difficult engineering
problem because you need to make this
material strong enough that it serves as a
vessel, right? It's got to
withstand blood pressure, not burst.
It's gotta be strong enough to put a
stitch into because you've got to sow this
into the natural artery.
So it's got to have good
mechanical properties on its own,
but still allow the formation of a
natural tissue around it and all those,
all those criteria turned
out to be difficult to meet.
I want to talk in, in, in, in
detail about it in advance.
That was made by someone
who's now here at Yale,
a woman named Lauren Nicholson and
she's in our department of Biomedical
Engineering and anesthesiology. And uh,
when she started looking at this problem,
she thought, well, everything that's done,
you know, it's, it's working kind of,
but it's not quite working well enough.
And that the vessels,
when you put them in the body, they don't
develop the way that normal vessels do.
They don't develop a normal structure.
And she thought maybe that's because
we're not exposing them to the,
to the kinds of environments that
arteries normally develop under.
And when our art or is developed
during embryonic development,
they developed as the heart developed,
right.
And while they were developing and turning
from just collections of cells into
arterial tissue,
they were exposed to flowing blood
because the embryonic heart was already
beating.
There's already an immature circulatory
system and these arteries develop in the
presence of a beating heart.
So what if you simulated that in cell
culture and took these tissue engineered
structures that are polymer scaffolds
filled with the right kinds of cells and
you hook them up to on both ends to a
tube where you can expose them to blood
flow and blood pressure and build a
reactor around these blood vessels so that
as they're developing outside the body,
you can control the conditions that
they're grown under so that it's close to
the conditions that unnatural artery
would experience when it's developing
inside an embryo.
And so this shows some of the things
that she did in order to create this, uh,
to create this environment.
Here's a picture of a bioreactor.
Here is an artificial blood vessel that
she made in the laboratory. And again,
this is a polymer scaffold,
the same kind of scaffold I showed
you several slides ago of a material,
uh, uh, uh, a network, an unwoven, uh,
Fiber Mesh and formed into a tube smooth
muscle cells or the internal cells of
the artery are cultured inside.
And then it's placed in this reactor and
you can see it's hooked up to two tubes
here.
So blood is constantly flowing through
the inside and it's flowing in a
pulsatile manner, just like our, uh,
our blood is flowing through our
coronary arteries or our artery.
And she found that if she did this,
they developed into
tissues that looked much,
much more like real arteries and that you
could take these and implant them into
animals. And one is shown here in the
carotid, in the, this is in the neck of,
um, of um, a large animal, I think either
as sheep or a pig, I'm not sure which one,
but it's stitched into place.
The animal then leaves the operating
room with a new blood vessel,
which you can study by using imaging
techniques and you can follow this blood
vessel. And they've done this for many,
many months now, even years in some cases.
And you can form vessels that are smaller
than any that have been transplanted
in this way. And um, and they
maintain their function in culture.
So I show this because I
think, what is it? It's an,
it's an exciting example of
tissue engineering. It's also,
I think a good illustration of one of
the advantages of tissue engineering in
that you can create a tissue outside
by arranging things together.
You can maintain it under controlled
conditions in the laboratory until it's
ready to be transplanted. And then you
can transplant it at the right time.
And all of these things are under control
so it could be optimized to produce
the best quality tissue.
In this case,
they've cultured the vessels for eight
weeks in order to get the kind of
function that they want.
I think you can imagine from
these examples I've shown
you lots of different, uh,
ways that you could
build outside the body,
neo tissues or structures
that will develop into,
into hopefully real tissues.
And this illustration is
just to sort of show you, uh,
all of the kinds of tissues that at this
point in time people have tried to make
using, uh, using tissue
engineering approaches. Uh,
many of you might know a Aaron Lovick
in our biomedical Engineering Department
who's been working.
Uh,
it has some fabulous results on tissue
engineering to create spinal cords to,
to treat injured spinal cords.
Um,
and there's many examples like this.
There's already tissue engineered skin
that's available for physicians to use.
And the other thing I tried to show you
with this diagram is that what you're
trying to achieve,
while you might be using the same
approaches that I've shown here,
you're trying to achieve different
things in different tissues.
Some things you're trying
to replace structure mainly.
So if I'm trying to use this
approach to make new bone,
I'm trying to make new
structural material.
What I care about is the mechanical
properties of the tissue that I create,
right?
At least like I care about that a lot
of bone that cannot form perform the
mechanical functions of bone
is not a very good bone, right?
It has to have the right elastic modulus,
which we talked about earlier.
And in other tissues you're trying
to replace metabolism or the cellular
biochemistry that goes on inside the cell.
So in the liver you don't care so much
about the mechanical properties of the
liver. You care that all
the cells are performing,
all the metabolic properties that
are liver ordinarily performs.
That table of things I showed
you last time in the pancreas.
In the same way you're trying to create
a tissue that forms a metabolic function.
And in the pancreas,
one of the most important metabolic
functions is that it senses glucose and
Secretes Insulin in response to glucose,
right?
You don't care about the structure,
you care about the metabolism.
And there are some things like, um, like
blood vessels where you're in between.
A blood vessel needs to perform.
A mechanical function needs to serve as
a physical plumbing to carry blood from
one place to another, but it also
performs a biological function. It,
it carries the blood and it anti
coagulates at the same time it stops
coagulation, right? And
there are many other, uh, uh,
bio biochemical functions
at blood vessels perform.
Okay. That next, uh,
aspect of tissue engineering I want to
focus on is that tissue engineering often
uses cellular processes
to control drug delivery.
So this provides a new
way to do drug delivery,
to supplement the kinds of engineering
approaches we talked about a few weeks
ago. Now how might you do
that? Well, let's imagine,
just look on this side of the slide here
and imagine you have a hollow fiber.
So a hollow fiber is a fiber that has
an outside diameter and then it's hollow
on the inside made of some
kind of synthetic material.
So it might look like a,
like a straw, you know, like a straw
that you drink through. Uh, only, uh,
only the straw has special
properties. And in general, it's much,
much thinner than this than
a drinking straw would be.
So this might be a millimeter across,
instead of,
you know, several millimeters
like a drinking straw would be,
and you fill this up with cells,
you fill up the hollow fiber with cells,
and the fiber is a special material
in that one. It's biocompatible,
so you can implanted in the body and the
body doesn't respond adversely to it.
And two, it has a controlled,
uh, has controlled,
uh, porosity so that
molecules can pass in and out.
So it's porous.
It allows molecules to pass in and out,
but it doesn't allow cells
to pass in and out. Right,
so it's a filter.
It's a porous filter that allows
small molecules to go in and out,
but doesn't allow large
molecules to go in and out.
Now this is filled up with cells and now
I show this cutaway so that you could
see inside, here's a little
clusters of cells growing inside,
but it's a full cylinder in reality and
the ends are sealed and I implant this
into the body.
Let's say I put it into the abdominal
cavity or I put it under the skin.
What you would like then is for these
cells to be able to communicate with the
body through molecules,
but not directly, right?
They're isolated from the body because
this hollow fiber is surrounding them
everywhere. And what if these
were cells from the pancreas?
Yeah.
Then maybe glucose,
blood sugar could could diffuse or move
through the wall of this hollow fiber,
exposing these cells to glucose.
The cells would sense the glucose is there
because their sales from the pancreas
and they're functioning normally,
and they would secrete insulin in response
to glucose and the insulin would flow
out and then into blood
vessels outside here. Now,
why go to all this trouble?
Why not just inject these cells?
Why not just inject these
cells right into the body?
Why surround them by this hollow fiber?
Okay.
What do you think would happen if you
just injected them under the skin or you
injected them into the abdominal cavity?
Kaitlin?
Yeah.
They would be recognized as foreign by
the immune system and unless they were
yourselves,
and you need this treatment because
cells aren't working properly,
right? So you don't have any
pancreas cells to contribute.
So the sales either have to come from
somebody else and aloe graft foreign to
you,
or it could even be a xenograft.
It might be cells from another species.
They might,
they might be sales from a pig,
for example.
And it turns out that the insulin that
pigs make is very similar to human
insulin. Not exactly the
same, but very similar.
And so for decades and decades until
we discovered ways to make recombinant
human insulin in the 1980s pig insulin
was the primary source of insulin to
treat diabetics.
So why not use cells from a species
where cells are readily available and put
them inside of a capsule like this so
that they're separated from your immune
system but still able to
function as a pancreas?
In a sense, it's functioning as a drug
delivery system. The drug here is insulin,
but it's a smart drug delivery system
and it has the intelligence of the cells
that are encapsulated inside.
And it's smart in what way?
It's smart in the fact that it can detect
the presence of glucose and Secrete
Insulin only when Glucose,
glucose is present and insulin is needed,
right? So if this was used to treat
diabetes, if you are a diabetic,
you wouldn't have to be checking your
glucose levels and adjusting how much you
inject because you'd have a system
inside your body that's doing it
automatically in the way,
hopefully that a normal pancreas is.
And what I show on the left hand
side of the graph here is, um,
some different configurations that people
have now made using the same concept.
It doesn't have to be a hollow fiber, but
you can make a, you can make a, um, um,
um, uh, micro capsule like this.
And remember when he made the algenate
particles in, uh, in the section meeting,
um,
uh,
we mentioned that not only could you put
food coloring inside these particles,
but maybe you could put cells
inside these and you can,
you can put cells inside these particles
and make little capsules that have
cells on the inside,
but it's surrounded by a barrier that
keeps them away from the immune system.
And there are a variety of other
ways of doing this as well. Again,
this next slide just shows you the
advantage of this strategy here.
The dashed line is the membrane,
whether it's formed by a hollow
fiber or an Algenate, a hydro gel,
a seal engineered cells are in the inside.
Uh,
now I talked about putting
cells from an animal inside,
but maybe you could genetically engineer
a Beta cells so that they function for
a long time.
Maybe you could take a patient's own
diseased cells and genetically engineer
them so they work properly
and then give them back.
Or maybe you could take a cells from
the pancreas of an individual donor,
genetically engineer them so
that they grow in culture, right?
And then they'd be available to
treat lots of patients. Um, and uh,
the idea is that nutrients,
oxygen, glucose can come inside.
Insulin can come back out,
but that the immune system
won't recognize it as foreign.
Now this is an idea that's also
been around for a long time.
There's been a lot of people
that have worked on it.
Great progress has been made.
It turns out to be a
tremendously challenging
engineering problem because you
need to engineer a material that's
compatible with the body that doesn't,
that allows only the passage of certain
molecules and not other molecules, right?
It has to allow insulin to
pass, but not antibodies. Uh,
it has to do that very reliably without
allowing any immune system components to
come inside. And it has to do
it at a high enough rate, right?
You have to not only allow
insulin to go through,
you have to allow it to go through in
large quantities so that you can provide
enough insulin in order to treat
diabetes without having a huge device.
Right? It needs to be small, so,
and produce a lot of insulin.
And these turn out to be, uh, challenges
that we haven't quite achieved yet.
Okay.
MMM.
So let me just summarize what
we've talked about, uh, in, in,
uh, the, the field of tissue engineering,
which I think you're gonna see, uh,
make a lot of progress
during your lifetime.
A logical extension of
conventional medical and
surgical practices and involves
the control or regulation
of normal healing.
And we talked about tissue engineering
approaches that use cells and tissue
engineering approaches that don't use
cells where the material or some other
aspect of what you're using a
controls the healing process.
We talked about tissue engineering to
supplement the cellular component and even
to guide the ways that cells form into
new tissues to control drug delivery.
And this last aspect which,
um,
which I think you can probably see more
clearly now than when I mentioned it
last time,
is that now you could use these new
tissues that are created in the laboratory
to understand physiology better.
You could take doctor Nicholas [inaudible]
tissue engineered blood vessels and
use them to understand more about how
blood vessels develop during embryonic
development because she's created this
system where she can control many of the
key variables.
You could add cells at different time
and see how this developing tissue
responds to that.
You could add signaling
molecules at different times
and see how this developing
tissue remodels or responds
to these signals that you had.
And so these turn out to
be very powerful tools,
not only for creating new therapies, for,
for understanding a human physiology.
Okay,
okay,
I'm going to stop there,
but there's time for questions and it
could be questions about this or last
minute questions about your
papers that are due tomorrow.
Any questions about that?
I know I've answered quite a few by email.
It seemed like everybody
was on the right track.
Nope, everybody's good. Good. So I'll
see you in section this afternoon.